now alligator you've noticed something
about British people and the way they
speak that we do a funny thing
no I mean I love all the every regional
you're not gonna use that scar mess but
I like that because there's so many
accents to such a small country
everybody sort of puts on different
voices when they're doing a little bit
so yeah yeah but I had a thing where I
was checking into a hotel and somebody
came out and said oh dude you'd help
with you bugs and I've I thought they
were doing a bit
kept talking like this I had to like
slowly transition out of it know that
that sounds like an exaggeration of
their voice but then I was back in the
country several years later and they
were on TV on goggle box cuz it was deaf
and Dom from God so they actually talk
like that I never knew that that was a
real hotel yeah you say there what's
that story you have about that you're a
very good friend of mine she was going
through a really stressful time and a
lovely arm said listen I'm gonna get you
a head massage so she went to this
clinic at a head massage she was in the
room and the woman said can you take
your knickers off ok ok yes so she took
her knickers off and she's like that and
then the woman came back in she was
South African she had no Nikolas Nikolas
[Applause]
Nicholas
to me
[Music]
you